You think about this and see for yourself, I myself had
seen this question for the first time, so
what happened, I will sit and think,
why do you do mathematics, tell me this thing, it is
all that you want marks in the board,
that is all but the most  The first thing that is related to
mathematics is
logic, you will be able to think things logically, it is
called problem solving, develop structured thinking,
this is what mathematics means,
if that thing is not developed then to match.
Tell me the meaning of 'There may be some marks left, maybe
you will bring it by any means, bye
rights and bike, whatever, I don't have money so that
you do something wrong, but you will also come to know
that it's okay, I take it, but
logic when you  If development is not done then it will
not be a live long learning nor will you
benefit forever
[praise]